心からなんです その場合
我々は現に実際に生きている
生きている時 使っている心
喋ったり行動したり考えたりする心
その心からの猛烈な物質が生まれっぱなしなんです
考える瞬間 瞬間 新しい物質を作っちゃう
喋る瞬間 瞬間 新しい物質を作ってしまっちゃう
体で行動を作る瞬間 瞬間
新しい物質を作りしまっちゃう
そこのところは問題なんです
なぜ問題かというと 我々は頓珍の考え方しか持ってない
ですから たとえ恵まれて生まれても
文句ばっかしの人生になってるんです
それは生まれたからの自分の心の在り方なんですね
だから誰でもいじってるのはそこら辺なんです
明るい思考をしてください
そうすると元気になりますよとかね
言ってるのはそのチッタのチッタサミッターのルーパの場合なんです
だからこのずーっと生まれてから死ぬまで悪い考え方ばっかり持っていたっても
完全に病気になって倒れて死んでしまったということはなく
まあいくらか元気でいるのはカルマはいい
いい物質を作ってくれる
一部はいい物質を作ってくれるんだけど
もう現在顕在的な自分がこの使っている心は悪い物質を作っているんですね
そこでまあ健康状態はそこそこの状態になってしまっちゃうんです
そこら辺理解すれば まあ人間の生き方はいくらかわかると思います
ですから ということは
どんな健康な赤ちゃんで生まれても
その人はその生まれた時からどういう心を持ってますかっていうことで
その人の将来は決められるんですね
赤ちゃんはすごい健康的になっても
形になったりするともうすごく病気になって体が悪くなる可能性あるし
食べすぎていろんなもうストレスばっかり溜まっちゃって
それで体が壊れる可能性はいくらでもあります
カルマが弱くなってくると
もう全然手に手の施しようは全くなし
だから人はカルマのせいで病気になるか
心のせいで病気になるかということはなかなか区別できないんです
カルマのせいで病気になっちゃうと
それはもう基本的なプログラムだから
もうどうしようもない
例えば DNA の何か問題があって体に異常があるというと
誰にもどうすることもできない
たまにそういう病気もありますね
そういうもう 100万人に一人ぐらいにはそういう病気は出ますけどとか
病気はあること知ってますけど
方法はない この筋肉がどんどんどんどん
あの 何て言いますか この
縮小していって もうそれでもう全部体が動かなくなってしまって死んでしまうんです
そういうふうなことはたまにあるんだけど
それは何でしょうかと誰もわからない
ですから それはやっぱりもう生まれる時のそういうプログラムになっていて
もうカルマがもうストップするんですね
自分で物質を作ることは
ストップ完全にストップするんじゃなくて
もう作る物質の量は少なくしちゃうんです
それでいくらご飯食べてももう 4 分の 1 が生まれてこないんだから
そこら辺まあ収縮していくんだと言わざるを得ないんです
まあそういう  じゃあ次に行きましょう
この 29 にあるのは別にあの気にしなくていいんだけど
イリヤパタウパッタンバラタ 29 番目パッタアッパナジャワナンイリヤパタンピサンナアメティというパーリ語の言葉であって
この意気の支持と書いて
その意気ですか  70種の心の中
この安心即病心 26 種類あります
これは意気を支える まあそこら辺はもう言わなくてもいいところで
まあそこはまあ皆様はわからないかもしれませんだけど
この あの これはアビダンマの世界の中で
こんな私の説明とはすっごいややこしく
きめ細かく分析するんだから
まあこちらはアビダンマじゃないんですから
このテキストは それはただアビダンマにどんな言葉を使うかという言葉の説明だけのことですから
で この禅定に入ったら
全ての機能は全ての機能といっても
普通の人間の機能っていうのはほとんどストップになっちゃうんですね
目があっても見えない
耳があっても聞こえない
認識しないんです 意識は他のところに集中しているんだから
体があっても触ってみたっても
その人はそれがわからない
でもその人の心は堂々と行動はしているんです
でも何も考えてもない
ある一つの対象だけ認識しているんです
そうするとアビダンマから見れば
その人はもう倒れて死ぬかもしれません
普通に言えばね 人間というのは見たり考えたり
体を動かしたり いろいろことを呼吸したりするのは当たり前である
いわゆる混乱状態は当たり前であってと思っているんです
じゃあ統一して統一して極力統一したら一つのことしかできないんではないか
それはまさにその通りなんです
統一してないんだから
私たちには見ながら喋れる
喋りながら音も聞こえていると感じている
それは統一してないんだから
どんどん統一して集中していっちゃうと
例えば見るものにずっと集中しちゃったら
もう人が喋っちゃっても聞こえなくなる
聞こえなくなる瞬間がありますから
そこはあまりの強烈な集中しちゃうと
聞こえることもなく 見えることもなく
集中したものしか認識しなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると人の体はどうなるんですか？という問題なんです
それを説明するために
この体の姿勢を その統一した心が守ってくれるんだと
ということは この座ったまま瞑想に入ったら
このどんどん統一して
この一つの対象だけ取っているようになっちゃう
それは安住状態というんですね
安しですか 安し状態というんですね
その状態になっても この体の姿勢はそのまんまなんです
動かないんです そういうふうに
この統一した心が この体の
その時の姿の状態はずっと守っているんだと
それだけの意味なんです
ですね あの 難しいことではないんですけどね
なんかこう お手洗はどこに出てるんです？全部カンマラですか
あの そこら辺のあの ちょっと省いたってもいいんです
この あの いろいろ この心から生まれる物質のことを説明しますけど
この次にこのエンヤって
三十と三十一は抜けても読みましょう
それはその辺で 三十二番に行きます
お父さん 何かトラブル
スィトゥンモホトゥ サマンニャータ テージョダートゥ テティッパッターワ ウトゥサムッターナ ルーパム アッジャッタムチャ
バヒッダンチャ ヤターラハン サムッターペティ
ジセツキインショ シ シキ
このジセツと何とかのウトというのは
このテージョーダートゥというこの
あの 火の元素なんですね
チースウィカーフーのカなんですね
で このカ この火という
カというこのエネルギーが
新しいエネルギーを作っていっちゃうんですね
パテリヤーポーテージョーワーヨーというんですけど
テージョーダートゥ チースウィカーフーの説明に僕は説明したと思います
ですから このチースウィカーフーの中で
この火と書く感じで このある素粒子の働きです
けど素粒子ではなくて
この変化の働きなんですね
その変化の働きするエネルギーが新しい物質を作っていくんだと
それはいつ作るかというところまできめ細かく書きますけど
この変化の あの カのエネルギーには生まれる瞬間で何もすることができない
生まれていて消えるという
この瞬間が三つに分けちゃうんですね
いわゆるどれぐらい長いといえば
まあ光の速度ぐらいに思ってもいいんです
いわゆる一秒の何分の1ぐらいかな
まあそれもわかりませんだけど
覚えてないんですけど
で ものすごい瞬間に物質が変化しちゃうんですね
その変化する瞬間 また三つに分けちゃうんですね
生まれる瞬間と止まってる瞬
ではなくて この生まれて消えちゃいますから
その生まれてずっと消えちゃう
また生まれてまた消えちゃうんですから
その生まれる瞬間は何もできませんし
死ぬ瞬間でも何もできません
あの ある瞬間に新しいエネルギーを作っちゃうんだということを言ってるんです
ですから 例えば私たちの体の中でチースウィカーフーがあるんですね
チースウィカーフーがあるんだ
チースウィカーフーで
もう最初の小さな素粒子が出来上がっちゃいますから
素粒子一個出来上がったらその中にチースウィカーフーがあるんだから
そのカがそのものをまた違うものに変化させちゃうんですね
だから変化からは逃げられないんです
どんな物質であろうが置いておくと
もうどんどん変化するんです
変化だけはストップはしないんです
なぜならば 一番我々知っているのは素粒子ですから
一番小さいものが 素粒子一個を見ても
それチースウィカーフーだから
そのものが変化してしまっちゃうんです
その法則がここでウトサムッターナドゥッカと言ってるんです
ジセツキインシキと言うんです
ですから この体はどう守ったって守られないんです
体はチースウィカーフーでできているんだから
そのカ自体がもう全部変化してしまっちゃうんです
だからいつでも変化しつつですね
物事は それはウトサムッターナというんです
それで外からカのエネルギー入っちゃうとまた変化する
だから一番変化わかるのは我々普通の
普通のこんな難しい言葉ではなくて
普通の常識で考えても
物事は一番変化早いのは
あの 火なんですね 火を入れてあげたら何でも変化する
米はご飯になってしまっちゃう
何のことなくすぐ変わってしまっちゃうんです
で この化学反応でもほとんどの場合はこの温めた方が反応が早いんですね
どうしても起こる化学反応なんですけど
まあ決まってる温度とか
我々洗濯機使う洗剤であろうとも
やっぱり水の温度がある場合はもう汚れは落ちやすいんですね
冷たい水であると になると汚れは落ちません
冷水では洗ってもあまり汚れが落ちない
でも温水で洗っちゃうと
もう簡単に汚れが落ちる
で その原因は何でしょうか
やっぱり温度なんですね
ただ温度あるだけで変化は早いんです
そこで服に沸騰している水なんか入れちゃったらもっと変化が早いんです
まあそんな感じで この知ってる世界の中でもすぐ変化する
変化させる原因は まあ火の元素であるということを考えてるんですね
で 最後の変化の原因はこのアーハールですね
はい そこでアーハールっていうのは
あのアーハールはまあ食
色食と書いて食 まあ食でもいいんですけど
まあなんか栄養みたいな意味ですけど
滋養素とも言ってましたから
その地水火風がいつでも一緒にいる
離れません その地水火風がまとめたら
ワンナガンダラサオージャ
色と滋養素 味と香りと滋養素と四つがつなげる
つなげますね それは前説明いたしました
地水火風があるところに色があって
味があって 香りの元素があって
それプラス滋養素という式があるんですね
実際にあるのは地水火風だけなんで
まとめたらそういう働きも二次的に生まれる
その滋養素っていうのは
自分持ってるエネルギーが他のエネルギーの塊に与えるっていうことなんですね
与えられる トランスすることができるんですね
ですから このまあ そんなに難しく考えないで
こう考えましょう 例えばご飯がありますね
ご飯にはエネルギーがあります
それ食べたら そのご飯の中にあるエネルギーは
細かく言えば これは太陽のエネルギーなんですね
それは太陽のエネルギーなんです
ご飯食べちゃったら 我々の体にそのエネルギーは入っちゃうんです
そこで我々も太陽のエネルギーで動いてるんですね
太陽のエネルギーで動いてるんだから
じゃあ日が当たるところにいれば元気ですかって言われても
それ元気になるわけじゃないんです
で 太陽にも熱エネルギーあるんだけど
それは我々の栄養にはならないんですね
やっぱりご飯かパンか何か食べなくちゃいけないんです
その場合は パンでもご飯でも他の穀物でも肉でも魚でも
その地水火風の中にある滋養素が
この地水火風の塊にトランスレーティングできるんですね
あの伝承できるんです
それでこの地水火風の塊によって
このどんなものからエネルギーを得られますかということは決まって決められます
例えばこのコアラとかそういう動物になっちゃうと
もう決まってる植物からエネルギーをもらっちゃうし
ライオンだったら肉からそのエネルギーをもらっちゃうし
ご飯食べてもライオンはあまりエネルギーは取らないんですね
で そういう風なことになってるんですね
クマさんだったらもう
もうどんなものからでも栄養を取ると
そういう風に まあ生命にはそれなりの食べ物があります
食べたりはする で それによって我々は新しい物質を作る
だから小さい時から小さい時の体が今すごくでっかくなっているのは
まあ結局は太陽のエネルギーなんですけど
それは食べ物を通してもらってるものなんです
そういう風に この一か所から他のところへこの式が変わっていくんですね
流れていくんです その流れていく法則はここでアーハールーパと言ってるんですね
アーハールからの意識が生まれるんだと
まあ大体この四つで私たちの体が出来上がってるんですね
その中で半分は心 半分じゃなくて3分の4分の1は心って
4分の1はカルマ 半分は我々の理解できる法則
お医者さんやら栄養士やら
普通みんな頑張ってるのはアーハールーパのところなんですね
病気になったら薬を飲む
それは体に何か欠けてる物質を与えてあげる
そうすると体は普通の状態に戻ると
ですから 仏教ではお腹が空くことを病気というんですね
人のお腹が空くことも一種の病気ですと
それで食べ物を与えてあげなくちゃいけない
そうでないと壊れてしまう
普通 病気というものも同じことで
同じものとして考えているんですね
空腹も一つの病気ですと
いわゆる物質は足らなくなっちゃうんですね
エネルギーが足らなくなっちゃう
それで調子がおかしくなっちゃう
それでその必要なエネルギーはそれから入れてあげるんですね
そこでコントロールできるのはどこら辺かというと
やっぱりコントロールできるのは心と心から生まれる物質はコントロールできる
それからアーハール要素から生まれる物質はコントロールできる
2つはコントロールできない
いわゆるカルマはもう生まれた瞬間の心カルマで決めちゃったんだから
それを心が生まれるたびにカルマの物質は生まれていっちゃうんですね
それはもう変化できない
で それで可能エネルギーで定常のエネルギーで体が変化するでしょ
体は放っておいたっても
体いじったっても変化していくんですね
それはどうすることもできない
わかりやすく言えば 人は年取って老化していっちゃうんですね
それはどうしてもストップすることはできないんですね
わかりやすく言えば 例えば DNA なんか今よく知ってるんだから
DNA で決まってるプログラムはもうどうしても手を入れることはできないんですね
その通りに体が変化していっちゃうんです
その 2つは変化不可能で
でもどんなものを食べるか
どんな薬を飲むかっていうことは我々にはコントロールできる
それからどんな心で自分が生きてますかということもコントロールできる
ですから 我々にコントロールできるのは半分であって
コントロールできない半分もあるんです
体についてはそういうふうなこと
次にある 34番目見てください
カムジョルーパディサルーパ
カムジョルーパ タッタハデーインディウィルーパニカムジャンエーワ
このカルマだけで 業だけで生まれるルーパがある
色があるんだと 物質があるんだと
カルマだけ 他の誰の何もどうすることもできない
いくら食べても全然影響を受けない
いくら運動したっても
いくら明るい心を持っていたっても
どうすることもできない
カルマだけで生まれる色があるんだ
どういう色かというと
ハデーインディウィルーパ
ハデーっていうのは心
心と書きますが この これは色なんですね
こちらでこの心 心と書いてるでしょ
その中 心気 次は根気ですかね
あ 根識 だから心識と根識って何ですか？とこの前説明いたしましたから
そこら辺は今日説明しません
で 心識っていうのは心ではありませんね
物質なんですね このどんな物質というと
この物質は物質ではありませんから
仏教で エネルギーですから
その これ体中あるんですね
とにかくその体中あるエネルギーが我々の心を支えているんですね
心を支えている物質に心識というんですね
心っていうのは意識無意識両方とも心ですからね
で それはもう大体どこかということははっきりわからない
我々の心はどこに住んでいるんですかと
言ったら 昔は心臓ですよと言ってきたんだけど
必ずしもそうなる必要はないんですね
お釈迦様は心臓ですよと言ってないんです
注釈書では心臓ですよと言ってるんです
だから注釈書は仏説ではないんだから
それはもう長老たちの考え方だから
なんで長老たちはそういうふうに心臓ですよと言ったかというと
それはやっぱりインドの一般的な概念なんですね
インドではこの魂は心臓の中に住んでるんですよというふうに考えていたんですね
ですから 魂というのは人間の人間たる一番基本的なところと思っていたんだから
それは心臓の中にいるならばということになっちゃったんだから
じゃあ心は心臓にしちゃいましょうと思ったかもしれません
でお釈迦様は その定義は何か
つかめないような定義するんですね
お釈迦様の定義は どんな色に基づいて我々の心が活動しているんですか？その色は心色であるというふうな定義なんですね
ということは どんな色でもいいということなんですね
特別にこの場所というふうに場所を言ってないんです
でお釈迦様場所言ってないのは
もしかするとお釈迦様は心の働き見たところで
もう体中心がどこでも動いているということはよくお分かりになったんだけど
インドでは絶対そういう考え方は当時ではなかったんですね
インドの言語の中ではそういう概念なかったんです
ですから言えないんです
そんなこと言っちゃったら頭おかしいと言われますから
ですから お釈迦様は大変苦労したと思いますよ
この科学は発展はしてなかったし
もう医学もそういう顕微鏡を通って
もう電子顕微鏡を通って勉強したりすることもなかったし
ですから やっぱり普通人間目で見て何か考えてやってた時代だから
その時代でこうどうな真理を喋ったってば
大変苦労しただろうと思います
ですから この体で この心がよりどころにしている物質は心色ですよと
そうすると我々は 例えば指を誰かに捻っちゃってひねられたら痛いし
そこに痛みが生まれるんだから
そこにも心が生まれる
目には心が生まれる 寒さは体で感じるんだから
体にも心が生まれる どこにでも感受性ありますから
どこにでも心が生まれる
そこで腸とか胃とか 我々は全然気にしませんだけど
やっぱり満腹になるとそれを知っている
空腹になるとそれを知っている
お腹が壊しちゃうと すごく痛みを感じる
やっぱりそこにも必要な時は心が生まれるということで
私の個人的な定義は 全ての細胞に心が活動しているんだと
そこで認識が生まれない場所として注釈書でも言っているのは
爪 爪ですね これは 爪 爪先とか髪の毛ぐらいなんです
そちらは心が生まれません
体の場合は体感じるのは痛みだけ
ですから医学では痛みだけ大事に思ってるんですね
ですから 脳細胞には痛み感じる神経はないんです
結局痛み感じるのは脳なんですけど
本人がすごいずるいんですね
自分が痛み感じないようにしてるんです
ですから 脳の手術する場合は
完全に麻酔しなくても大丈夫なんですね
皮膚だけ麻酔して それから手術もう何のことなくできるんですね
人と喋りながら どこに痛みない
それでも脳の中いじるとね
いろんな考え方やらいろんなものも見えたり聞こえたり
いろいろ起こりますから
そこにもちゃんと心は生まれる
痛み生まれませんだけど
肉体の中では痛みしか生まれません
人生っていうのは楽は楽しいなとみんな思ってますけど
結局細胞は痛みしか感知しないんです
そこで痛みは少ないか強いかそれだけのことなんです
疲れてる人はソファーに座って
ああ気持ちいいわ 楽だと思うだけのことで
もう何時間もソファーに座ってるとすごい痛いんですね
痛くてしょうがないんですね
ですから 結局感じるのは痛みだけなんですね
ですから 一生懸命痛み変化しながら生きてるんですね
ある痛みを感じていて
それが強烈になってくると違う痛みに変化する
痛みから痛みと頑張ってるんです
言って みんなやっぱり人生っていうのは幸福だ
楽しいだともう楽はいっぱいあるんだとというふうな説教をするんです
で あの  その 2つ 心識と
次に言ってるのはこの想色ですね
想色はカルマから生まれるんだと
想色はどこで出てきたんですか
180？ 184 ページにあります
パサード バーロ ジービタという
8種類あるんです じゃあもう一回ちょっと説明いたしますけど
パサードルーパっていうのは情色
それは 5つあるんですね
それは原 二 備 触 思という 5つはパサードルーパ
バールーパっていうのは
男性か女性かと決めるこの性色 2つなんですね
次にジービタルーパという名色というルーパがあるんですね
その 8種類 じゃあここで言っているのは
この我々のこの見える力
聞こえる力 味わえる力
変わりを嗅いだりすることできるその嗅げる力
それから体の感触 そのエネルギーはカルマから生まれているんですね
で もうどうすることもできない
変化できない 次に名色という命として
この物質は生きている物質ですから
一つこの命としても何か働いているんです
そういうものはカルマからですと
ですから いじることはできない
それはこの白くとは 例えば目の見える力といっても白くとは関係ないんです
見えるか見えないかと
どれぐらい見えるか見えないかということはもうずっと同じなんです
我々視力っていうのはこの目の構造の問題なんですね
ですから 生まれてからの目が弱い人は
まあずっと目が弱いんです
いきなり抜群に目が見えるようになったということはないんです
そうなったならば それは闘争の問題で
目が見える力のことじゃないんです
音の場合も同じで ですから
あまり使うすぎると そういうのは力がなくなっちゃうんです
例えば耳が音を聴くためにあって
それはどんどんどんどんものすごく音を聴いて聴いてしまっちゃうと
そのカルマが弱ってしまっちゃうんです
それで耳がもう聞こえなくなっちゃうんです
味ももう同じく いろんな味を味わって味わっていっちゃうと
どんどんもう味覚が鈍くなって消えてしまっちゃう
また生き返ることはできないんです
カルマが消えちゃった
ですから そこら辺カルマですから
死ぬまでどれぐらいエネルギーかっていうことはもう決まってるんです
そこで人の寿命もカルマで決めてるんです
それは心識の問題で 心識っていうのは心を支えている物質的なエネルギーだから
それはもうカルマであって
その人の寿命はそこで決められるんです
そこで心識が弱くなってくると
そこに心が生まれなくなっちゃうんです
早く死ぬ そう早くではなくて
その人が死んでしまっちゃうんです
ですからだからって必ずしも心識が弱いんだから人は死んだわけじゃなくて
もう食べないでいても死ぬし
事故に遭っても死ぬし
他の物質が壊れたらその時でも死んでしまっちゃいますけど
寿命があっても まあそういうことで
そこで心だけ 心だけ作る識が二つあるんです
食べ物にはできない カルマにはできない
それはヴィンニャーっていうことで
カーヤ・ヴィンニャーという様識なんですね
いわゆる表現識かな 表現する時のエネルギー
我々が他人に何か表現したい場合は
言葉で 音で言うか 体で言うか
どっちかなんですね 体を動かしてこっち来てください
あっち行ってくださいとか体で言えるんですし
あるいは音で言うんですね
それは全部心から生まれるんだと
そこでディジャルーとサットーチットジャとチットートゥジョー
ある一つの識がありまして
心と鬱っていうのは物質的なエネルギーですから
か あの 定常ですね 可 可元素
かの元素ですね その 2つで生まれるのはサド音ですと
だからちょっと混乱するかもしれませんだけど
人間 形式って何ですかと
カウィニャとワチウィニャと 2つありますね
体で人に表現する で 言葉で人
あるいは音で人に表現する
そうするとそれは心から生まれるというんですね
そうすると全ての言葉が
音が心で生まれるのではないかと言えますが
またここにややこしい区別するんですね
で ただ音だけだったら
別に何か表してるわけじゃないんです
何か言いたくて言ってるわけじゃない
ただの音だったら いろんなところを作られる
例えば指でもなんとか音をこうやって作られますからね
それも音なんですね で
こうやって指で私は指を動かす音を作る場合は
別に何か言ってるわけじゃなくて
音を作ってるだけなんです
その場合は意識がありまして
意識で指を動かしている
でも指物質的に動かないと変化しない
といわゆる可能幻想がなければここに音は生まれません
それで喉から出てくる音も同じで
力踏ん張って出さないと音にならないんです
だからただの音と何か表現する時の音という
その表現力が区別してるだけのことなんですね
なんでそこまで細かいかっていうことは
ちょっと私もわかりません
そこで 3つの原因で生まれるのてラフターディッターヤンウチュチッターレサンドーティ
そこで 3つで 3つの原因で生まれる色がありまして
4つの原因で生まれる色があると言ってるんです
そこら辺はまあ説明はしなくてもいいと思います
次に出てくるのはナクトーチルーパ
ラッカネルーパアイナクトーチジャヤンティ
無意識 どんな原因でもなく生まれる色があるんだと
どんな原因もなく生まれるというか
ちょっとおかしい話なんですけど
何にも頼ってなくなく生まれる色があるんだと
それは結局色じゃないんです
これはアニッラッカネルーパなんですね
それはパーリ語では覚えていますか？ウパチャヤサンタティジャラタアニッチャタという 4つあるんです
ウパチャヤっていうのは物質が現れる
サンタティというのは物質はいくらか現れて
ちょっと生き続く ジャラタというのは物質は変化して老化する
アニッチャタというのは物質は消えていく
結局生まれて消えていくということなんです
結局無常ということなんです
だからものは生まれて消えていくという現象は別に何か原因がってるわけじゃないと言ってるんですね
それはカルマだからですよ
心からですよ 言っちゃ言ってないんですね
これは論理的な問題と思いますけどね
別にこの あの 物事は変化するということは当たり前であって
これはしょうがないもので
で もの 変化には特別なまた原因は探してないんですね
どうせ可能幻想あるんだから物事は変化する
この変化自体別な色で見ているんだからそこがおかしいだけなんです
アビダンマでは変化自体は別に存在するものではない
変化という物質はあるわけないんだから
そこら辺でこの古い人々のこの分析のやり方なんですね
もう分析はキリとするんだけど
どこかですごく大雑把というか
いい加減というか 現代的な理論にはなかなか当てはまらないんですね
きちんと物質説明します
きちんと物質説明してほしいんですね
そこで物質はちゃんと説明して
物質の特色も別な物質として見ているんです
物質があって特色があるんだから
それでウパージャヤルーパというんですね
エシ色と そこら辺 そんなに我々の現代的な知識からいうと
ちょっと理解しにくいところ
理解しにくいというよりは
現代的な知識ではそんなことやったらちょっとおかしいんです
このエシ色というたくさんありますけど
それは全部この色として扱っちゃいけないんです
でもアビダンマでは扱ってるんです
本当はアビダンマでも言ってるんです
色は 4つなんですね チーヴィカ
その 4つまとめたところで
人の体見るとありとあらゆる働きがあるんですね
それを別々に色だと色だと言ってるんです
で 基本的な 4つとまた出てくるのはこの原因比出身の働きなんで
感受性なんです それもまとめたら